I said in June as the terrorist group  ISIL began an advance across Iraq that  the United States would be prepared to  take targeted military action in Iraq if  and when we determined that the  situation required in recent days these  terrorists have continued to move across  Iraq and have neared the city of Erbil  where American diplomats and civilians  serve at our consulate and American  military personnel advisor Aki forces to  stop the advance on Erbil I've directed  our military to take targeted strikes  against ISIL terrorist convoys should  they move toward the city we intend to  stay vigilant and then take action if  these terrorist forces threaten our  personnel or facilities anywhere in Iraq  including our consulate in Erbil and our  embassy in Baghdad we're also providing  urgent assistance to Iraqi government  and Kurdish forces so they can more  effectively wage the fight against ISIL